hi I'm Sal Khan founder of the
not-for-profit Khan Academy and if you
are thinking about going to law school
know someone who is or just care about
equity of opportunity I have some very
exciting news we are announcing Khan
Academy is announcing the availability
of free test preparation for the L SAT
the law school admissions test this is a
really big deal over a hundred thousand
people who are aspiring lawyers take the
L SAT every year many of them paying for
test prep that costs hundreds or even
thousands of dollars and you can imagine
that hits a lot of young people's
pocketbooks or even is inaccessible to
many people and what's especially
exciting about our partnership to create
the world's best preparation for the L
SAT is that it's being done in
conjunction with the makers of the test
the law school admissions council so
we're very excited about this we think
it's going to help empower a new
generation of lawyers and it follows in
the tradition of work that we've done
with the College Board around the SAT
which over three million students have
taken advantage of our free test prep
here at Khan Academy we have a mission
of a free world-class education for
anyone anywhere and we're excited about
increasing the level of opportunity for
aspiring law students starting soon